with a major shift in the pandemic fight
after the fda gave full approval to the
pfizer vaccine for americans 16 and up
afterward many employers and
universities started issuing ultimatums
telling workers and students to get the
vaccine or they cannot return in person
yesterday president biden encouraged
americans who were waiting for full
approval to get their shots immediately
calling the fda announcement the gold
standard our lead national correspondent
david begneau is in hard hit lafayette
louisiana david good morning
anthony good morning get this pfizer
submitted an application that was
360 thousand pages of safety data and
rigorous inspections the fda has
reportedly never received so much data
before judging the safety of a shot
it was the fda's full approval of the
pfizer vaccine that convinced year old
kalyn mcgee to line up at a vaccine
clinic at the university of louisiana at
lafayette yesterday and get vaccinated
what did you think when you heard about
the fda approval i was just being
ignored at that point
like it was my own fault so i just had
to go do it like there's really no
running away from it anymore
nineteen-year-old cali roselle had also
been on the fence about vaccination for
months but that finally changed
yesterday full approval from fda is what
did it for you yes
it is that's what did it for me and
we're also going to be required on
campus the fda's full approval was
swiftly met by several new vaccination
mandates the pentagon is moving ahead
with a vaccination requirement for all
active duty service members
new york city public schools mandated at
least one shot for all teachers and
staff by september 27th and united
airlines which had already announced a
vaccine mandate says that its staff must
be fully vaccinated by that same date
scott kirby is united ceo it seemed like
an absolute no-brainer and a requirement
from a safety perspective that we
require vaccines but i also believe
that's going to be
more common to require vaccines than to
not require vaccines within the next few
weeks
[Applause]
and while some people may challenge
those mandates don't expect a judge to
overturn them says cbs news legal
analyst ricky clement historically
mandates work according to the law that
is a government a business
a university can demand that people get
vaccinated there were many people who
felt that it did not have full approval
and therefore it was risky to get it
that argument goes right out the door
because with full approval
it is therefore looked at as a safe
vaccine
so the full approval applies to those 16
and older full approval for the younger
kids experts say probably won't come
until the fall and at the end of the day
the fda says when you look at all the
clinical data and the clinical trial
data
the coven 19 vaccine from pfizer is 91
effective at preventing covet 19 disease
gail
david thank you